après trois semaines intenses
le juge peter k il a laissé les 12 jurés
se retirer avec une mission décider de
la culpabilité ou non de derek chauvine
dans la mort de george clooney
le procès s'est terminé ce lundi avec
les mêmes images dans boucle celle de
l'agonie de georges floyd sous le genou
de l'ex policier le 25 mai dernier
pour ce dernier jour l'accusation et la
défense sont à tour de rôle pris la
parole et pour le procureur la
culpabilité de derek chauvine ne fait
aucun doute
nous appelons la police lorsque nous
avons besoin d aide
et il a supplié monsieur l'agent les
derniers mots de georges floyd le 25 mai
2020 sur s'il vous plaît je ne peux pas
respirer et il a dit ces mots à l'accusé
jugé pour homicide involontaire et
violences volontaires ayant entraîné la
mort de georges floyd derek chauvine n'a
pas souhaité témoigner pendant ces trois
semaines de procès mais la défense a
tout de même demandé l'acquittement
après une plaidoirie de plus de trois
heures pour elle la mort de l'homme de
46 ans peut avoir été causé par de
multiples facteurs comme la consommation
de drogue et l'état de son coeur
lorsque vous examiner l'ensemble des
preuves
ouah lorsque vous examinez la loi telle
qu'elle est écrite et que vous concluez
tout cela l'état échoué à apporter la
preuve au delà du doute raisonnable et
monsieur chauvine doit par conséquent
être déclaré non coupable de tous les
chefs d'accusation washington présente
pour ce dernier jour du procès la
famille de georges floyd n'avait qu'un
seul message à faire passer
remercier tous ceux qui les ont soutenus
je voudrais remercier la communauté et
je voudrais remercier tous ceux qui dans
le monde entier sont solidaires avec
nous nous recevons tellement de messages
et nous vous en remercions
nous répondons autant que nous pouvons
merci à tous pour votre soutien dans le
monde entier c'est aux douze jurés que
revient désormais de décider si derek
chauvine est coupable ou non le délibéré
pourrait prendre plusieurs jours pour
arriver à une décision unanime sur
chacune des trois charges retenues
contre derek chauvine
s'il est reconnu coupable l'ex-policier
encourt jusqu'à 40 ans de prison